on the dish this morning Valentine
Thomas as far as we know this is the
first chef or cookbook author we've
featured who both captures and Cooks
their own Seafood now she's out with a
new cookbook called good catch
we will dive into that soon but first
a different kind of Plunge
[Music]
so we're in Florida Keys right now we're
I think right of Tavernier what are we
gonna do we're gonna go spearfishing
Fear fishing is the common name for it
but Valentine Thomas actually prefers
something else
Blue Water hunting
Thomas can hold her breath for six
minutes and Dives up to 170 feet with no
scuba gear
just the tool of her trade and you just
load it you aim and you
and you want to show that it's enough
and you're my protection today I will be
your protection today you said something
to me about if I if the shark gets too
close what do I do so the shot gets too
close just act tough act like a predator
if the shark comes towards you try to go
towards the shark he's not gonna like it
and just make your space and he should
be fine hopefully good go that way about
50 feet and go ahead and do your drop
unlike in regular fishing when you're
left with whatever bites
spearing allows you to track and Target
you got the lionfish in this case an
invasive species that kills native
populations if left unchecked lionfish
Thomas warns not to touch them however
nice
[Music]
with a Snapper in hand it was time for
our first treat prepared Dockside you
don't need much to make with cvj really
good you just want to put
lime juice cilantro a little bit of red
onion
salt pepper and you're pretty much good
to go
Valentine Thomas grew up in Montreal
an anxious kid prone to panic attacks as
a teenager one near-death experience
scarred her deeply I was about 14 years
old and I went for a swim I was in the
south of France and I got caught in an
undertow The Lifeguard come and grab me
and then it just brought me back to it
to the helicopter and everything and
then I did not swim into the ocean for
about 10 years after that 10 years 10
years after that after she finished
school Thomas moved to London where she
became a high-powered businesswoman
until she quit to embrace her new career
everybody thought I was stupid which is
fair enough I
I have a law degree I have a master in
law I worked on a hedge fund in London I
had a good job I was making good money I
didn't have a reason really to quit
everything other than you weren't happy
other than I was unhappy I needed
something different different includes
becoming an advocate for sustainable
fishing a free dive instructor a social
media sensation and a published author
with her new cookbook good catch
for her full dish presentation Thomas
unveiled some of those recipes
so delicious I can tell already you
ready the First Choice was not a Thomas
idea but a glory one
pickled fish eyeballs
ah waste not want not right uh
amazing I almost believe you
[Laughter]
I do a few things you'll likely find
more eye-catching including that
lionfish Thomas caught earlier served
with a reduction of apple cider vinegar
soy sauce and maple syrup so the maple
syrup is really cool in here
needed a Quebec Dutch it's like a little
Quebec a little Canada
that is so good right oh my gosh that's
amazing lionfish as one of my favorite
Fish Eagle that was followed with a
smoked fish dip with lemon and salt and
vinegar chips a nod to her London days
another Ceviche also with Snapper this
time using pineapple Tabasco and lime
fish tacos with lemon cream cheese sauce
and pickled cucumber
and panzanella salad with Snapper feta
cheese Capers cucumber and tomatoes with
an oregano grapefruit and lemon dressing
plus a classic Florida key lime pie
oddly enough I never cooked the same
thing twice
why because I believe that there's so
many different flavors combination in
the world that my life is too short to
try them all so every time I cook I try
to do something different every time
different can be a challenge
but it can also take you to depths you
might have never dreamed possible
it did for Thomas
in more ways than one being a woman and
a fishing in the street I need to work
double to work on my credibility but at
the same time I think it did open more
doors to me that it would happen with a
man do you feel like some people still
look at you and say like oh I don't take
it seriously 100 yeah there's no none
about that and how do you feel about
that
I tell them come back with me let's see
who goes deeper laughs
I like her so do we come die when we see
who goes deeper we brought you guys
fresh off the boat in Montauk this is
striped bass not eyeballs just caught no
yeah
soy sauce lime and because we're feeling
a little frisky this morning a little
orange zest so try that
try it try that out it's really good oh
yummy